et nous partons tout de suite en
saône-et-loire eric sicaud département
le plus incertain de cet entre deux
tours
oui gauche et droite sont au coude à
coude un en saône et loire la partie
s'annonce donc serré dimanche cet
après-midi le ps et ses alliés ont donc
organisé une conférence de presse à la
maison des associations de lui près de
chalon-sur-saône
ils ont appelé à la mobilisation pour
tenter de conserver la majorité face à
une droite dont il dénonce l'absence de
programme écoutez le secrétaire fédérale
socialiste jérôme durand au micro de
damien beauty et romy watch
on y croit ça va être la bagarre pour le
15e quand on sait que dans 14 cantons ça
peut passer
et donc c'est ce canton qu'il fallait
chercher on est tous mobilisés pour
conserver la majorité
la campagne de la droite sur le bilan
n'a pas fonctionné il aurait dû être
plus haut donc maintenant qu'on est sur
le projet dans cet entre deux tours
c'est un autre avantage
je pense que dimanche regardera la
majorité direction le nord côte-d'or à
présent s'intéresse ce soir à
l'entre-deux tours dans le canton de
rombas oui là les électeurs ont le choix
entre un duel classique un gauche droite
à l'issue du premier tour le binôme udi
avec une avance d'environ 200 voix mais
son adversaire de gauche veut y croire
dans les deux camps depuis lundi on
s'attelle et surtout à convaincre les
abstentionnistes reportage bintou sidibé
et jean françois guillemot quelques
heures à peine après le premier tour et
les voilà repartis sur le terrain un
seul mot d'ordre convaincre c'est à ce
n'est ni chez un agriculteur que
laurence porte et marc frot candidats
udi ont rendez-vous ce jour-là le binôme
arrivé en tête avec seulement 197 voix
espère récupérer le vote des
abstentionnistes mais aussi de ceux qui
dimanche dernier ont fait un autre choix
que l'idée à bayonne a potentiellement
sûrement qu'on n'a pas convaincu donc on
fait le forcing
non c'est simplement pour expliquer on
est des élus de proximité et peut-être
que
que les gens l'oublient un petit peu
donc on est en train de rappeler tout ce
que fait le conseil général alors avec
les obligations transport scolaire route
et aussi les choses facultative qui nous
paraissent important d'aider les pme et
d'aider le monde agricole
donc voilà on essaie de dire qu'on est
là présent et qu'ils peuvent compter sur
du côté des forces du progrès patrick
molinoz et son équipe peaufinent leur
stratégie du second tour
donc cette semaine déjà en vain se
mettre en mouvement on l'est déjà depuis
ce matin on analyse on regarde les
résultats dans l'ensemble des communes
du nouveau canton le conseiller sortant
de venarey-les-laumes y croit encore ils
comptent surtout sur le report des voix
des partis de gauche mais pas seulement
je sais déjà qu'il ya des gens qui sont
obtenues au premier tour en visant
d'abord il y aura un deuxième parce qu'à
cinq candidats passer à 60% que la
dernière fois c'est pas possible
et puis on préfère y aller au deuxième
pour faut être sûr que cela avons bien
venir la semaine prochaine qui est pas
de démotivation et qu'on rencontre les
gens c'est ce qu'on va faire pendant
toute la semaine je pense sincèrement
comme tous les candidats union de la
droite contre union de la gauche
le duel s'annonce très serrée dans le
canton de montbard les électeurs du
front national dont les candidats ont
obtenu 21% pourrait bien jouer les
arbitres de cette deuxième mi temps
une information france 3 bourgogne à
propos de la campagne dans l'yonne oui
vous le savez dans ce département le fn
est arrivé en tête dans dix cantons il
reste présent dans 19 des 20 cantons
votera dimanche des élus d'extrême
droite pourrait donc faire leur entrée
au conseil départemental une idée que
refuse le président eût dit andré
villiers il a appelé dès dimanche soir à
faire barrage au fn et il va plus loin
aujourd'hui et c'est une première il
invite à une réunion commune les
candidats de droite et de gauche
et ce sont des candidats opposés au
front national uni
réunion républicaine en quelque sorte
réunion prévue à 16h30 demain à germiny
cette situation continue d'alimenter
twitter avec par exemple cette fuite du
candidat de gauche de saint florentin
thierry corniot éliminé dimanche
depuis deux jours je passe mon temps à
consoler les gens autour de moi un
comble et c'est pas grave
en fait si ça peut le devenir conclut-il
allusion à la possible élection du
candidat fn
et puis un autre tweet au se félicitent
les deux candidats de gauche de pont sur
yonne qui font honneur à la république
dit il et à la gauche icaunaise en se
désistant en côte d'or la campagne
continue
oui avec jean philippe morel par exemple
en ballottage défavorable à l'envi il
semble supplié les électeurs le conseil
départemental restera à droite et au
centre dimanche ne restait pas en marge
de l'histoire écrit-il
de leur côté les jeunes socialistes
continuent à relayer la campagne en
publiant des photos de porte à porte
comme ici dans le canton de dijon 6
enfin sachez que la liste de tous les
candidats étaient validées et publiées
sur le site du ministère de l'intérieur
comme il l'a fait savoir lui même sur
twitter ce matin
et n'oubliez pas dimanche notre soirée
spéciale élections départementales sur
france 3 bourgogne dès 19h